muy buenos días Ángela quedan menos de
24 horas de oxígeno en ese sumergible
Así que el tiempo apremia pero la última
información como dices ofrece esperanza
y son estos sonidos de golpe que se han
registrado unos sonidos con
intermitentes de entre 30 y 30 minutos
han sido recogidos por un avión
canadiense que participa en las labores
de búsqueda y según ha explicado la
guardia costera estaríamos hablando de
unas señales de supervivencia continua
que dan Esperanza Mientras tanto se
siguen sumando cada vez más ayuda a
estas labores de búsqueda no solamente
ha entrado a participar también los
equipos militares estadounidenses sino
que también está llegando ayuda de los
países de origen de los supervivientes
Francia por ejemplo ha enviado un robot
submarino que permite bajar a mucha
profundidad para ver para ayudar en esas
labores de rescate llegará hoy mismo
porque como dijo el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron lo más importante ahora
mismo
es el tiempo el país británico también
ha ofrecido su ayuda y es que no
solamente se trata de máquinas y
dispositivos que son bastante avanzados
tecnológicamente y que es difícil de
utilizar también hay que encontrar esas
personas que sepan manejarlos
mamen qué tan seguro está el sumergible
si la página web de la propia empresa ya
hizo un comunicado hace tiempo
explicando que su sumergible no estaba
clasificado en ninguna empresa ninguna
organización porque al parecer es tan
moderno que eso llevaría muchísimos años
una clasificación Pues que garantiza que
haya salvavidas suficientes y que se
cumplan una serie de requisitos técnicos
y mecánicos así pues también dijeron que
su aparato es tan moderno que era
imposible que se clasificará Por qué
decían esto Pues bien porque el casco
del sumergible en vez de estar realizado
con fibras de carbono por ejemplo está
hecho está realizado con fibras de
carbono en vez de estar hecho con Acero
lo que permite mantener mejor la presión
ante gran profundidad Así que antes de
subir a este sumergible los
participantes tienen que firmar un
documento en el que dice que asumen esta
información y que están dispuestos a
hacerlo a pesar de que corren el riesgo
de sufrir heridas o incluso la muerte